turning overseas meetings between the
leaders of China and Russia are entering
a second day in Moscow ahead of a big
state dinner there Xi Jinping and
Vladimir Putin held more than four hours
of talks yesterday it was an opportunity
it would appear for them to flaunt their
so-called No Limits friendship all in
defiance of the West and in defiance of
global criticism of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Liz Palmer has more
arrived
and a warm greeting in the Kremlin from
President Vladimir Putin who called him
last February at the Beijing Winter
Olympics the two men first declared that
friendship was Without Limits
it's since been tested by Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
and by the international Criminal
Court's arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin as a suspected war criminal
China has recently published a ceasefire
plan for Ukraine but its terms were
don't call for a Russian withdrawal have
been dismissed by the White House
falling for a ceasefire that does not
include the removal of Russian forces
from Ukrainian territory would
effectively be supporting the
ratification of Russian Conquest
it would recognize Russia's attempts to
seize the Sovereign neighbor's territory
by force
today president XI and Putin are likely
to discuss Ukraine a breakthrough isn't
likely though it's expected that she
will soon speak with Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski and Western officials
don't believe China has committed to
supplying Russia with weapons
high on today's meeting agenda will be
trade under heavy Western sanctions
Russia depends more than ever on China
for goods and services and to buy its
oil and gas
president XI is well placed to drive a
hard bargain with a man who may not be
the ideal friend but who he can at least
count on to stand with China against its
main rival
the United States
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo